welcome to this video this is an
coverage of round six of my tournament
but visa Germany opened Bavarian
championships we have round six I was on
four and a half four point five points
out of five only conceding this one draw
against the top seed so very nice
tournament up to this point in round six
I got one of the highest rated players
of the tournament an exam the Lenderman
from the u.s. almost rated 2600 it's
probably best known to the American
audience II of my channel because he has
participated in a number of American or
US Championships in the last couple of
years he had a very good championship
this year where he they looked like yeah
maybe like maybe wins the thing but at
the NTM I'm not sure yeah I think he got
third place or something in the playoffs
he he was leading from most of the
tournament okay I had black not so great
against a super strong player but okay
what can you do let's have a look I got
the bow go Indian yeah
my preparation to be honest it wasn't
that it wasn't that long I saw that
Lenderman plays yeah deform c4 and night
f3 on this one so all kinds of lines he
also plays both 93 here for the
nimzo-indian for catalan yeah so it was
very hard to predict what he will play
so I was thinking okay let's just play
my normal repertoire and see what
happens so we got the bow go and he went
Bishop d2 okay a5 is my my mafia the
move that I also will discuss early in
my book and he went a3 yeah funny he
managed to play the exact line that I
had forgot
to analyze this was nice so that
actually this game reminded me that this
is existing and I should address it in
my book that it was a bit uncomfortable
to face this move simply because it's
it's really the one gap that I that I
still still had it seems yeah okay I
take on d2 and Queen takes yeah it's not
a three it's not a move that scares like
much but it was still uncomfortable to
be facing it yeah castles 93
yeah with a three Black has some
basically only this option to take on
the two and now Queen d2 is the thing
that what that white wants to achieve he
wants to have the Queen on d2 and
especially the knight on c3 the knight
on c3 is just an active piece and a
better place than any knight on D - yeah
here the problem is for black not a
problem but the thing is that in some
comparable positions he would like to
play d5 and what I mean with comparable
is the position without those moves a3
and a5 um if we jump back to this
position there is also this line and
here d5 has an excellent reputation for
black as being a very very good
equalizer in a way after something like
III Queen e7 rook c1 you know this kind
of thing is very very equal but if we
now look at my game position let's jump
back if I now play d5 here the problem
is that if we consider something very
similar and something like this we see
that a5 is really a move that I don't
want to have in this position weakening
b5 weakening b6 this insertion of moves
is very much in White's favor so a d5
setup
it's not really recommended but it's not
a problem
I can play with d6 as I usually do in
the structure so I went d6
he played a for ya a nice point of white
setup what gets this this big Center
I played knight c6 he played rook to d1
yeah I'm the move d5 here kicking of the
night is not very dangerous I can just
drop to his 7 yeah and if I get in a 5 I
get the structure that I want actually
with night on g6 so I don't even have to
spend a move with Queen e7 to prepare a
5 yeah d5 isn't very scary he played
rook t1 and he played it immediately it
was a bit uncomfortable
he had dashed out all those moves and
instantly basically and I had to think a
little bit because I was really thinking
okay have I looked at this before this
is something that I should remember yeah
well I simply had to play this over the
board words I think I managed quite
alright yeah I looked you one what rook
e1 does is it prevents e5 ium I simply
cannot play the move you know it just
blunders upon so unfortunately I need a
prep move for this so I went Queen
okay Queenie 7 and he played there
should be 2 yeah there is some nothing
better really I was thinking a bit about
a 5 this is a move but it's not very
much of a problem I can take drop back
and now e5 is a slight liability he
coming he can cover it sorry Queenie 3
and then something like b6 this type of
position is certainly not a problem for
black or maybe Bishop to b7 now they
have a solid structure on the Queen side
and I'm not getting checkmated anytime
soon with with this this kind of bishop
so
it's quite okay from like he went be
should be too
I think this is better than you find
okay II five and D 5 yeah taking is
really not promising much after Knight
takes I think I should should be okay
so he went d5 and I went night to be
eight yeah this is the only possible way
to play at night to d8 really as a not a
good idea the night is not coming into
the game quickly okay he played before
yeah this is due to the fact that the
move a form can be a bit annoying for
white if I get in let's say let's play a
little bit of wishful thinking something
like this yeah and I get Bishop to d7
925 yeah black has an excellent position
then the Queen side is blockaded and
where's White's playing so I understand
to the B form with played again
relatively quickly yeah
here we come to an interesting and
interesting moment in the analysis
afterwards he said that my move
surprised him the Bishop g4 that and no
plate yeah well in my experience from
analyzing this position type and I have
this position type a number of times in
my book my experience is that this
Bishop on c8 is while technically being
the good bishop it's very often a piece
that black has literally used for so
very often I think that a trade on on g4
is quite a good idea this wasn't the
only possibility here an interesting
move who also was Knight h5 intending to
jump there and after g3 just drop back
yeah
intending Bishop h3 to disturb white
also not not a bad choice
yeah but I think my movies is perfectly
okay Bishop g4 it's interesting he not
played 8/3 yes forcing the trade that I
would have played anyway so I was
surprised but he considered this trade
to be a good for him um but okay
afterwards we pretty much agreed that
it's not leading to that much
well Age 3 I took them I took B form and
I went 96 you can also play Knight BD 7
which is the slightly slightly a more
passive option it's not bad but it's a
little bit a little bit passive I had
another idea a different idea
Knight a6 it attacks the before porn I
was basically expecting rook b1 here but
he surprised me with Knight b5
interesting move after rook b1 it was my
plan to play c5 takes takes and this
type of position in the game we get
exactly the same structure but I think
under slightly more favorable
circumstances for black which means that
we both had probably about equal but in
the game it was a little bit a little
bit more coordinated in my position this
he said that he when he went Knight b5
he he hoped that I wouldn't play Knight
e8 okay this is yeah I think 98 is very
obvious but he did he didn't he didn't
he is speculated that I might didn't
play it and what is the idea of 95 the
idea is that I cannot play the C pawn
now and I mean something like that for
example he will take and grab and it is
a little bit difficult for black to
untangle without pushing the C pawn at
some point if I don't play 98 he can
build up
with moves like castles rook a1 rook a
for those kind of moves and yeah it
might be a little bit better but I play
98 yeah and it was pretty clear to me
quickly that I should do that
preparing c6 the point is that he am he
not played rugby 1 which is the best
move but if he castles then I go c6
Posse 5 but see success is more forceful
and the point is that this is a very
comfortable endgame for black
it's simply nothing for white I have a
pretty good night here compared to a
somewhat somewhat clumsy Bishop White
has ideas to activate it yes c5 and get
around here but this is still absolutely
nothing for him and it's a somewhat
simplified position already so he has
very little chances to to do something
in terms of playing for win and of
course with white against someone 150
points lower he wants to try to win um
so he avoided that and he played rook to
be one in this position yeah yeah of
course now c6 kicking this nine out and
it went back so we have a situation
where years spent time on Knight b5 and
back what I have played 98 that probably
will move back again so it's not a huge
difference if we consider the next moves
knives here
castles 96 yeah I was glad to have this
night a 6 routed to e6 now this is one
reason why c6 is an essential move for
black trading D against C pawn without
the d5 pawn in the middle of the board
we have this e 6 square even intending
to plant a knight on d4 very nice yeah
he planted a plant he played night e 2
now covering the weekend d4 square
instead she that also was a move b5
after b5 I think black should just keep
the position something something like
Queen Queen b7 as a move 94 is also
possible that Queen B 7 SS okay he must
be a bit cautious with advancing b5
because it even it weakens those squares
c5 especially we can defy it's not a
difference but c5 is weakened and he has
to be careful with the structure because
his bishop is potentially really bad so
he didn't play be five but nighty - I
think this is also better 92 Knight f6
back rook to d1 Luke to d6 and around
here I was really satisfied black has no
bad piece or potentially bad piece those
Knights have good positions as a knight
always has his intention to jump to
deform the f6 Knight put some pressure
on e4 and I really don't have a serious
weakness d6 is securely covered and it's
difficult for him to make any any
progress
c5 it's very tough to play and even if
he gets it in it's not doing that much
or b5
yeah well gives away c5 but what what
else is there so it's difficult he went
through k1 and I had the feeling that he
was really not very much satisfied with
his position he looked very looked
somewhat uncomfortable I was thinking
and yeah maybe this tempted me a bit to
be honest yeah he I took a longer thing
and it came up with an idea that
ultimately backfired enormous ly I now
took on a1 which is okay it's not that's
not an issue but here in this position I
made a mistake really not a mistake
probably a huge mistake
technically if you ask the computer it
says it's not the best move and the
position
that shouldn't lose but it got me into
trouble really yeah I can do very simple
I can do something very simple I can
just stay and ask him okay how are you
going to win this game what is your
intention to beat me how are you going
to do it I should just play something
like let's say queen bee 7 or H 6 so
this kind of move and as I mentioned
before it's difficult for white to
change the structure favorably and lots
of scenarios are quite ok for me and
let's say this position with rooks and
Queen traded a pure minor piece endgame
there even black is like a slightly more
comfortable because of those pawns on
light squares the bishop is not so great
so white probably has to play and if he
wants to win has to play very in a very
slow manner
yeah like g3 Bishop g2 maybe f4 at some
point this kind of idea but this also
gives me counter chances I should have
just stayed here in a way and not change
the position very much and then see what
he comes up with what I were what I did
was I hate I was tempted by this move
the central break it's not looking to be
honest I don't think it's it's it's such
a totally illogical looking move because
I have a very nicely centralized
position and the pieces are activated in
a way but it has a concrete drawbacks
and frankly I just miscalculated
something very simple
he took which was clear that basically
the only move and now he form this was
also obvious Bishop g4 has to save it
and now I took on d5 yeah my idea now is
that if he if he allows it I will do
something like let's say place if I for
instance then I can take on g4 and play
d4 and I really like this position it
looked at look
tempting yeah okay he has those two
points but I have a good Center and his
King side is slightly weakened yeah I
have ideas like this or maybe III it
looked like an interesting interesting
position and one thing that's very
important to note is that the situation
for this game was a little bit difficult
for me I had four and a half out of five
which sounds nice but the thing is if
you want to score a grandmaster norm you
need a certain rating average of your
opponents that's 2380 average rating and
unfortunately I had very low rated
opponents especially the round five
opponent where I also I was close to to
get a very strong opponent I got a very
weak one in comparison with 2,200 so my
average rating was very low and it was
clear that with the loss in this game
I'm definitely out of any chances for a
GM norm and even with the drawn it was
difficult because there was there was a
slight fear that with the draw I might
get a weaker opponent again so hey and
no I'm not saying I needed to win the
game but it was it was tempting to sort
of complicate matters a bit maybe trying
to test him with time ticking down and
as mentioned he looked uncomfortable so
I was tempted to do something concrete
and this was not a good idea
the thing is he didn't play c5 he took
on e6 this I had expected but I made a
very simple miscalculation I now took on
c4 and this recapture is not really
great after c5 e v c6 white white spawns
are much more dangerous a big difference
to the line before is that the white
king is very safe here and this is just
bad for black so after the capture only
six I had to take on c4 and this I had
anticipated but what I did not really
see clearly before
is that after the capture here King
takes I have to take with the King
because Queen takes hangs rook and queen
c3 beforehand what I didn't really
appreciate very much is that c4 Hanks
and I cannot really go rook to e3 I was
always thinking I have this rope d3 move
but here I recognized that after Queen
c3 of course I cannot play Luke t3 it
takes you just take c4 his check not
very nice I immediately recognized that
the whole operation wasn't really great
but still the position is not not so bad
I played Queen to c7 covering the c4
upon which is okay yeah and here we
counter an interesting moment here I was
expecting the move Roxy one very much
and I was asking myself if I really have
what I should do here one line that I
had calculated is rook to e3 and this
has given us the best line by the
computer quite amazingly I had
calculated this line yeah this rook at
game in which black yah has so suffer
especially against the determined
opponent computer is quite surprisingly
just on 0.24 white I would think that
white is quite substantially better here
with the rook covering the pawn from the
side I have chances to to walk I'm sorry
not this to to to switch the King over
to the to the to the Queen side yeah I
had calculated this and I was thinking
okay rook c1 is a bit uncomfortable if I
cannot play rook to e3 I mean a move
like rook c8 does not look very
attractive and I was just about to
calculate this when he played b5 and I
was I was thinking oh that's my
b5 he's not really worried about rook t3
Wow now here I can play whoop t3 and
then I relatively quickly played this
move and basically when I was putting it
on d3 I noticed that that I really made
a mistake with this move but yeah what
is it that I should have done and the
problem with this is b6 I can I should
tell you maybe right away the problem is
b6 this move is very annoying now a
counter-attack on the Queen and yeah
after this in the game I was suffering a
lot with my open King what I should have
done is I should have played queen c5
removing the screen from any attacks
with b6 still keeping a7 covered after
Queen c5 I think black still has some
excellent chances to get to get an equal
position there is not that much
happening really b6 for example here I
can take take and go to g6 this is
something that is not possible in the
game because in the game I have the rook
here on d3 where it gets hit with a
check here I can go to g6 and this is
not super comfortable but I think black
should be okay here for example if he
gives us check King h6 Quincy one
intending a discovered check I can go
here and to g6 White is still a little
bit more comfortable he has to save a
king but this is something that black
normally should not lose this is what I
should have done I actually think that
he should have played rooks e1 instead
of b5 but I didn't take this chance
I played rook to e3 relatively quickly
instead and with the move I simply I
ever to be 6 it was just like I put it
there and oh no
and maybe six and well the problem is
you cannot really not take Edea I was
briefly thinking about Quincy five but
Rukh a seven King f8 96 this kind of
stuff looks very very problematic White
is also clearly better him so I just I
just took this this bloody pawn queen
takes come on Queen takes Queen takes
and he took on c4 of course yeah and
here the issue is King g6 runs into the
check quite comparable to this line
where I'm also losing material this
means hmm I have to move the king the
only King whisking to e7 and well my
King is just in the middle of the board
and he has this easy to see me Luke
Asics attacking my queen and yeah it is
just not very very nice this position is
I guess lost in a practical game the
computers on +1 maybe yeah I mean the
computer definitely defends better than
then then I can I can defend but it is
really impossible to defend the open
King yeah I think in a practical game I
went here and he played g3 that's a good
movement making sure that he's not mated
and gif raid first I wanted to play rook
to 6 but then I noticed that something
like that is also really terrible I mean
no moves and he will come in with his
Knight to one of those two squares on 93
sometimes it is it is a lost position
yeah I went rook d5 oops not troop to
6000 group d5 basically not knowing what
to play rook g5 94 and yeah all three
pieces attack I gave the check and went
here of course is not trading White has
a mating attack now
a seven check rooty seven and Queenie
six yeah
after here I'm going to get checkmated
and I went to d8 which is not much
better of course
Ruka a check and after that I resigned
after king c7 queen c6 i mated yeah this
was a bit disappointing I must admit
because I was really satisfied with my
position around move 22 if we jump back
there this moved 24 actually Here I am I
was really satisfied with my position
and I should have just sit sit tight
here yeah and play play slow improving
moves asking him okay show me what you
got can you win this well what is your
idea and it would have been also the
better strategy in terms of trying to
generate winning chances simply hoping
that in the with his ambition to win the
game that he does something that it's
not totally justified so this was the
key position of the game after d5 I got
in some trouble not necessarily a
position that is so bad that I should
lose but after after that I really am
yeah put me in a situation where needed
to find lots of only moves and
technically sound moves which which is
getting more difficult with time time
going down so it was some disappointing
yeah so no no chances anymore for for
for Grandmaster norm in this tournament
I know that it is difficult for me to to
score such norm 2600 is really really
high of a performance to play but say
you have to try if you play there
without any specific ambition it's it's
not much fun so after this the
tournament in terms of scoring a GM norm
was was basically over
but there were still three games to play
and they were interesting so I think
there's something to look forward to in
the coverage of round seven eight and
nine yeah thanks for watching